here with reaction former FBI agent
Nicole Parker and Fox News contributor
Tammy Bruce uh Nicole let me start based
on your background in the in the FBI a
10 23 I don't know if that's something
that we would want as a conservative for
public dissemination however we're
talking about congressional oversight
here this is being requested by a the
head of a committee and a leading
Senator uh Charles Grassley so the
question is if a whistleblower is making
that severe and that specific an
allegation they believe that the
Whistleblower is credible
why won't they at least let them see or
understand or investigate what it is
that the Whistleblower is saying
right so let me start by explaining an
fd-1023 is for open source this is out
there this is not a secret but it is a
source reporting document and the FBI we
run things called confidential human
sources or chs's so the fd-1023 is where
you document what a source tells you it
goes into a system and it is safe from
anything they do not reveal Source
information when I left the FBI when
you're at the FBI there are three things
that they tell you you never reveal
classified information Source reporting
information and sensitive investigative
techniques so it doesn't shock me that
they are not willing to turn over the
1023 they're saying that it's in the
name of National Security but this is
from Congress this is a subpoena in my
personal opinion I don't believe that
they'll ever turn over this ft 1023 but
time will tell for a whistleblower to
come forward we know that it takes a lot
of courage to be a whistleblower when I
took an oath as an FBI agent I took an
oath to uphold the Constitution of the
United States of America I did not take
an oath to uphold an Administration and
to you know follow their lead or follow
the guidance of doj I uphold the
Constitution of the United States of
America for this whistleblower to come
forward they felt strongly enough about
this fd-1023 that they were aware of
that they felt that it was necessary to
report this information and I commend
The Whistleblower for doing this I do
too and all right Tammy so if it's an
unproven allegation uh and it is
chronicled
um we are talking about senior officials
in the House and Senate uh why not
provide them an opportunity to see it in
a private skiff and not make it public
until but at least give them a road map
for their investigation
well because and this is what bothers
the American people as it should is that
federal law enforcement certainly since
revealed via Donald Trump and what they
did to him uh it has become completely
politicized that's what it appears to be
and if our federal law enforcement is
using its its position using its power
uh for political ends this is not just a
danger to democracy this is the thing
that indicates that democracy is broken
and it also is a reminder to the
American people because we have a Law
and Order issues here Americans very
often at the local and state levels
complain about the Need For Justice
Reform so when you get a signal from
federal law enforcement that that the
rules don't matter that you're not going
to comply with a subpoena that the
reality is is that you know the FBI is
not an island unto itself it's not a
Sovereign Nation it doesn't get to say
no to the oversight body itself in the
senate or in the house when it comes to
to this is why they exist why there is
oversight so that we can make sure that
laws are not being broken that
partisanship is not driving prosecutions
or persecutions it was a six-page letter
Sean that they sent to say no and they
and then there was some patronizing in
it it was oh you know there's a reason
why we call it confidential human
sources and we're going to keep it
confidential and and these are our
elected officials the people who work
for us to deal with the FBI and anybody
else who is in the bureaucracy who has
hired or who is appointed so that we
know things are on the up and up and
they are blatantly saying we we have no
time for you as much as they were
blatantly setting up Donald Trump as an
example lying to the fisa court you know
getting involved in the fake Russia
dossier so we have a legitimacy issue
with the government as a whole no matter
what party you belong to that this is
the kind a Behavior now that doesn't
just start overnight that it is infested
within a system and this is why
oversight exists to deal with this
specifically so and their refusal
reinforces the need to get this
information and Nicole so if if they
believe this source and The
Whistleblower the question is why won't
the FBI at least meet with them
privately look at the allegation and
maybe answer the question whether or not
they did follow-up and did the
investigation uh into what is alleged
here
you know Sean that's a great question if
I was the FBI director things would
probably be very different but I'm not
so I can't really give you a fair answer
but what I can tell you I think it'd be
better than the one we have but go ahead
well I I don't know but what I can tell
you is that the Whistleblower is coming
forward for a reason right and I don't
know I don't know this FD 1023 I've
never seen it but think about it if the
Whistleblower is coming forward the FBI
is saying we can't confirm or deny that
there's an investigation
if the fd-23 if if there's an
investigation going on probably maybe
they're protecting Biden isn't that the
whole point that they may be protecting
Joe Biden
right I mean it we'll we'll see what
happens but um there The Whistleblower
has a reason that they're coming forward
let's just say that right all right
Nicole thank you Tammy great job as
always thank you hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else